drawing combination with knight takes c3  knight takes  knight d4  queen somewhere  takes and now it's perpetual check  so the game is over  draw that means  bishyana can no longer  win the tournament  pregnant any  any other options here for black or just  a normal game what do you think  i guess  if black doesn't take the draw it's kind  of uh art for black yeah yeah you can't  castle queenside we're looking at  king h1 after which you can maybe castle  the gold play for d4 but after queen e2  i guess it's too much because this pawn  is hanging  yeah it's probably  not a big choice for vichy here  yeah his yesterday game was quite  painful  yeah that was rough  would you have resigned there after  queen b5 or would you have waited to see  i would have waited